welcome to a new talk the main stage
here at P data we have a super exciting
talk now we are going to become expert
at choosing kpis metric and we have draw
and Alan here to host us so drw is a
data scientist lead at meta and Alan is
a data scientist lead at Spotify So yeah
thank you for being here and let's give
them some
Applause
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone uh I hope you
had a nice break and got a nice snack uh
I sure did so uh Welcome to our talk
thank you for choosing us we'll talk
about power users longtail users and
everything in between know how to
measure metrics how to choose meaningful
metrics and KP for product
strategy uh as Pier said I'm alone I'm
uh edit scientist at Spotify and I'm
visiting from the UK I'm Ro I'm a data
scientist Tech Le for meta based here in
Amsterdam so let's see what the agenda
is for today we'll start by setting the
scene with a few brief introductions
into the data science role and
responsibilities then we'll spend the
majority of the time talking about the
different hats at data scientist needs
to aware and after that we'll conclude
and open the floor for some questions so
without further Ado let's jump
in the Insight teams in Tech
organizations and not just are very very
varied there are all sorts of different
job roles and people complement each
other in their skills and uh abilities
and the disciplines they come from and
represent this is a partial list uh your
mileage may vary but roughly these are
five of the big categories and if you
remember the opening remarks this
morning we saw that while data scientist
is the most common job role for
attendees at P data it's not the
majority of attendees and so it's good
to keep that in mind when we are talking
what what we mean when we talking about
data scientists we are this slice of the
population and data scientists come in
all different flavors uh I try to list
the main ones here but it's really is
very varied and d and I belong to this
of product data scientist and draw will
say what that means yeah so why do
companies even pay product analytics uh
it's I think not clear for anyone um but
while ml Engineers actually build stuff
right and ranking models Etc the things
that we try to help companies do is to
make better decisions in order to make
better decisions uh you need data and
you mostly need causal inference you
need to try and understand what the
effect will be of certain policies um
there's this nice framework that we use
at meta which I really like called
understand identify and execute uh which
talks about the three different pillars
of how you build a product at the first
stage which is the understand stage you
try to get the lay of the land see what
you want to do and figure out what
direction you want to take and sort of
where do you want to take your company
or organization or team towards this is
the part where we as product analytics
data scientists try and Define Northstar
metrics for our teams uh and we will
focus the majority of the talk today on
that how do you choose the right North
Star metrics after you figure out what
it is that you're trying to optimize for
as a team you then try toate identify
concrete opportunities to get you
towards that direction and after you've
identified and prioritized the
opportunities that you want to pursue
you then go to execute and make sure
that you're executing as planned as that
and that you've exhausted the
opportunities that you were able to
identify maybe another way to think
about this is we do stuff in hindsight
which is basically trying to be reactive
figuring out what's going on in the
world and then how do we want to act
upon it and we do things in foreset
figuring out where we want to go to and
then what would be the best PA path
towards that and whether whether or not
whether if you're reactive or proactive
you have to be active in order to be
active you need to be making decisions
in order to make the right decisions you
want to utilize data um so how do you do
that in practice what are the different
hats that we wear when we're coming up
with these metrics
so the bulk of the talk is going to talk
about the three hats that we wear as
product analytics data scientists first
one is the stat statisticians hat um
this is like the science part of data
science and this is making sure that
really the data is valid and that we
stand behind it then we have the
business H yes we have the business hat
which is sort of the more soft skills
part of the operation where you try to
go beyond the statistics and into the
actual product strategy and the
management of the team and then lastly
we have the practitioner's head about
how you take the theoretical aspect and
then translate them into actual things
that you can use so I will now hand it
over to Alan to start and go walk us
through the statisticians
hat thank you so uh we identified eight
Key properties that metrics should have
are obviously it's a wish list your
mileage may vary uh you not necessarily
be able to get all of them we will cover
the first six and the other two are
reserved for pi data Plus
members number eight will shock you um
you can take photos we'll also have uh
we also have all of that already on
GitHub and uh slides and video will be
added a bit later but the key uh
ingredients of this talk are already
available on the link that we'll have
later on so uh when we are talking about
different uh properties we are going to
use this silly framework of good idea
bad idea D and I uh were kids in the
'90s so if you know this reference we
really like you if you don't we still
like you but you know play along with us
and we'll begin with clearance simple
who here knows what a net promoter score
is oh dear um well so uh hopefully uh
everybody feels the same as me about NPS
but for those of you for the few of you
that didn't raise their hands NPS is
this measure to see how happy users are
with your product and so you've seen
these before you've got an email so pop
up saying on a scale of 0 to 10 an 11
point scale is already a good thing a
good way to start um How likely are you
recommend this thing to a friend and
then you collect the answers of
different users and you label them so
anyone who gave between zero and six is
a detractor nine and 10 are promoter and
those in between the seven and E are
neutrals um I should say that as I
mentioned I'm from the UK in the UK
nobody gives anything nine or a 10 like
eight is uh eight is the English
10 after doing that you uh completely
ignore the neutrals you shrink all the
data to two groups uh detractors and
promoters and the net promoter score is
the proportion of promoters minus the
proportion of detractors times 100 so I
think it already it's fairly clear that
it's not clear and not simple not easy
to do or
convey but uh there are other issues
with that as well it doesn't really tell
you a lot
um on the right you can see two
different
distributions both of them give you an
NPS of one Z right and I would argue
that the distribution the blue
Distribution on the right is actually a
very good story most of the people gave
seven and eight and they are really H
which means they are fairly happy fairly
content with your product Some Gave nine
and even those that don't like your
product or aren't as Keen it gave at6
which is still pretty good and then on
the other hand it has exactly the same
NPS score as the one person that gave a
zero and the one person that gave a 10
combined so it's very convoluted uh I'm
not a fan as you can imagine and so I
would suggest a better idea which would
be two things customer satisfaction
surveys and you need to Overlay with
retention and engagement metrics because
just because somebody's using your
product doesn't mean they like
it um another key ingredient is for E to
be measurable reliable and accurate
obviously if I conduct a measure today
and I conduct it tomorrow and get vastly
different numbers just because uh that's
not very useful or if I report numbers
monthly or quarterly and I run the same
calculation and I show that the numbers
in history somehow miraculously changed
that's not very usable but uh there are
also other issues like selection effects
and survivorship bias so for example in
The NPS example you can assume or or
suspect that the users that will give
you are more likely to reply are people
that are either very happy or very
annoyed with your product and so a
better idea could be a for example the
customer satisfaction satisfaction
survey uh after debiasing before we dive
into that I'll just share an obligatory
slide and give you a second to read
it
and with that draw will tell us what we
can do about it yes so this is just a
quick Shameless plug for a new library
out by the core data science team at
meta uh those are the smart folks with
the PHD in statistics they've put out a
python package for debiasing uh your
data sets it's optimized for surveys
um they also published like a 44 Page
Long article that gives a really good
survey of the lay of the land of
packages available in Python and INR and
also of the different methods being used
it also includes a tutorial um I've been
using the internal version for quite a
while for um de biasing data sets around
experimentation Etc it's super easy to
use um and I highly recommend it so this
was like a quick word from our sponsor
and then back to our regular
programming cool so uh the the next r
is Missy mutually exclusive collectively
exhaustive so we need to make sure that
we represent all of our users and all of
our users one so not not accidentally
over um overweight them so
uh this uh so like the first part is of
what can be taken care of by what draw
just said we'll make sure that even
though we may have some extremes to who
uh chooses to answer the survey
then we can kind of rebalance it to be
more representative of the uh user base
but we also need to keep in mind that we
don't want to over represent anyone we
want to have an understanding of all of
our user base
combined the next principle is timely uh
and basically what we mean by that is
that good enough Now is better than
perfect later so uh you may have uh seen
retention charts before basically uh we
see uh the vertical axis is the percent
of users that were attained and then the
horizontal axis is for time so it could
be days months weeks and what you would
uh see in many many cases is this uh
shape of Rapid decline in the first
couple of periods and then a linear uh
Trend afterwards so once you've made it
through some threshold the reasons
people live are because of like death
and marriage death if you know their
device dies and they can't look back in
or the you know the person dies or
marriage so if two people have an EIC
account and then they move to to live in
the same flat they are going to downsize
but other than that the trend is pretty
much linear and so instead of waiting 12
months to get 12 months data for
attention for example you can look at
the first three four extrapolate and
know that where you haded what's what's
working better than many other options
for
example uh this is a cute one this is
one of my favorites uh obviously it kind
of seems like table Stakes but still um
it needs to be informative and
actionable and a few years ago Bing
search uh changed the search algo and
they saw in an experiment that there was
an optic of 10% in queries per user and
30% in Revenue per user which is
phenomenal right we should be lucky to
have one1 of that so there was a problem
they had a bug that degraded the search
results so people searched more because
they couldn't find good results and they
spent more time on the website because
they couldn't find what they were
looking for so the problem is that the
action taken from this uh metric alone
is to Let's the greatest SE soge for
everyone and make more
money um so I would say that a better
idea would be to also track uh uh task
success for example in retention you can
have shortterm wins but long-term
fails and one other thing to keep in
mind is uh standardization that would
also help with uh all of the issues that
I mentioned before
and
basically through uh playbooks and tools
we can kind of speak the same language
inside the data science or uh and make
sure that things that we do and take for
granted are also things that other
people in the company do and take for
granted um a common example is for
example retention if you needed to uh
calculate monthly retention I'm sure
that some of you calculated it with uh
30-day Windows whereas other people in
your company calculated retention with
28 day windows so that's one example and
on the right there's my Shameless plug
for confidence which is uh a a platform
will uh release soon for uh
experimentation so just to sum things up
these are the different um properties
that I discussed
and as I mentioned you can already go to
our GitHub and see all of this in person
in person and with that the second hat
the MBA hat is going to draw yeah okay
so we have this metrics it sound we
stand behind it we believe that the
numbers make sense this is not going to
be sufficient on its own to make a team
successful right and to actually drive
business success so how do we do that I
wanted to cover like four topics here
one I want to briefly mention kpis and
okrs I'm sure that you've heard of it
uh people tend to use it interchangeably
in the industry but I want to go over
what they are and then I want to talk
over some other um principles to keep in
mind
so very basically kpis key performance
indicators okr's objectives and key
results I won't go through the they are
like nuely different it's mostly a
question of how stable your environment
is and how sure you are that you're
going to continue to try to do the same
thing over and over for a longer period
but both of them have what both of them
have in common is is that they're both
trying to get you to Define measurable
quantifiable measurable ways that will
be clear to tell you if you're going in
the right direction or not now you can
do it for a variety of directions that
you might want to go down and I'm sure
that in companies and the larger the
company you work
in the more directions you will try to
pull at um one of those kpis or okrs or
let's say if not one then up to three
has to be defined as your North Star
metric okay the good thing about a North
star is that there's only one of them
and that's how you know the actual North
right so same thing here you want to
help your
organization figure out what's the
Northstar metric that everyone wants to
prioritize um this means that when
everyone are going to make multiple
decisions throughout the day in
different teams about info and front end
and backend and whatnot and promotions
everyone's are going everyone's going to
try to optimize for the same thing and
once everyone agrees that this is the
thing
that we all measure together and we're
all trying to optimize for that means
that we're not only uh doing going at
the right direction we're also going
fast there right we're all focused and
that's why as data scientist helping
your organization Define and track your
Northstar metric is one of the most
influential levers that we have on
managing and actually driving strategy
in the org um so what metrics do you
want to track or how do you know know
what metric other companies um
competitors might track um my tip here
is go to quarterly reports um that
public companies post um especially if
you're going to interview for one figure
out what's the metrics that they're
talking with stakeholders about I
guarantee you that those are metrics
that everyone in the organization really
cares about um and try to internalize
what that metric means and how it might
move now I've listed some here so
Facebook and Instagram are looking at
daily active users monthly active users
Spotify is looking at uh paying paying
monthly active users and AD based
monthly active users um YouTube actually
had internal debates about what should
be the Northstar metric uh after they
were required by Google people who came
from information retrieval basically
really didn't like the fact that they
were trying to optimize for Time video
watch time the argument was if we have
if someone is searching how to tie a tie
and we have two videos one that is going
to give the answer in 30 seconds and one
that is going to be really entertaining
with many jokes but it's going to take 5
minutes we want to give the users the
ability to get the information in 30
seconds the understanding within
YouTube's leadership was that YouTube is
not going to be like Google in that
sense it's actually they were trying to
get the product to be entertaining and
the competition was television so
actually what they wanted was for people
to view longer videos even at the
expense of watching fewer videos right
so norstar metric super super important
the downside there is that people can
always game metrics okay so as an
unmentioned about Bing same story goes
with YouTube they had this reranking
algorithm that really increased the
number of videos that people were
watching but it was actually downranking
the relevant videos so people had to go
through many videos uh that's not a good
thing it is great for metrics it's
something that you can celebrate if
everyone's just looking at the metric
another thing that we need to do as the
like business hat people in the room is
to say okay we're actually trying to
optimize for users not for metrics um I
have a nice anecdote about the USSR and
nails but I'll keep that for the Q&A
session um this is a real world example
oh like how do you know if something is
a North star metric for or an
organization I find it helpful when Mark
Zuckerberg tells the world um so if you
if you get a chance to do that that will
probably help here's what Mark
Zuckerberg had to say about the
Northstar metrics and how to think about
the direction for Threads after the
launch and as you can see the idea is
we're going to focus on retention first
as Al mentioned earlier we don't want to
focus on acquisition the first thing is
to get the basics right and make sure
that we have a retentive product in
place after we figure that out and we
find product Market F then we can go to
try and expand the community get more
acquisition and only after that will we
talk about Revenue um keep in mind that
different segments of your users Drive
different
metrics bottom
line if you plot any metric in the real
world it is likely going to have this um
Power law or longtail
distribution where the mode of the users
will have very low values of the metric
and then you'll have a small Subs
segment of users that have really high
value for the metric uh
it's not working but the power users
part those will be the ones that really
like your product they're going to be
the ones that are driving your
engagement metrics and those will be the
subs segment of users that you want to
focus on and understand better if you
want to drive engagement the users on
the left those are the users that are
not uh sure that they're going to retain
they don't like the product that much
and those are the users that you want to
focus on if you want to improve
retention and drive growth that way
um
and that's me um so let's start with the
left hand side of the of the slide
you've probably seen this before the
product diffusion curve basically early
on it's the tech gigs it's the early
adopters the ones that are really happy
to try anything new and uh maybe not
necessarily fully flashed out the better
T and ters and so on and then over time
I part becomes more and more mainstream
and then even later adopter so for me I
can think about like smartphone adoption
right uh I was uh I was fairly early on
replaced my candy bar uh cell phone to a
smartphone and then over time even my
parents kind of decided that okay we
need to change and so on and my mom is
now she you can get it off uh uh
WhatsApp and kind of flickering through
images so users or the makeup of your
user base will change over time and that
also is relevant because they'll change
it differently and then on the right
hand side you can see the kind of the uh
the the hype cycle diagram where you
know new technology we think that oh
it's amazing it can do everything it's
the solution to all of our problems and
then there comes some uh disillusionment
where okay maybe not and then finally we
reach some steady state that we know
what's good and what we can do and what
we can't do and that also affects your
metric right on how people use your
product and what they are trying to do
with it and what are they expecting from
it so in case you wondering uh if H how
realistic this curve is here's some
recent uh usage stats for
jgpt so that's the blue line and uh I
bet you weren't expecting
that so to sum up uh we have the four
principles for an MBA um and I will hand
it back to draw to talk about the
practitioner hat cool so the pr
practitioner hat is really all about
okay these were nice in theory we
graduated now what do we bring to the
actual business right
um our main like takeaway here is that
without data a DS would just be a person
with an opinion right like you don't
have any advantage over any other
partner that you're working with but
without an opinion you're just a person
with data right like you're not really
helpful in any way for the business what
you really want to have is you want to
have data that you stand behind and you
also want to be opinionated about the
direction that the team should go at or
the organization should go at um not
going to talk over all eight principles
I do want to talk about some of them but
I want to call out the
three that I won't say more about anyway
um make sure that your organization is
also prioritizing measuring the impact
this also means having a culture of
experimentation there's this tension
that people feel like oh in order to
execute well we should just focus on
making impact at not measuring it make
sure that you incentivize people to also
measure their impact um this also means
invest in building the data sets that
will help you come up with the insights
that will help you do the understand
work and then also make sure to leverage
things Beyond data um for being
opinionated right so make sure to
leverage product vision and uxr Etc um
your data in order to stand behind the
data like Vicki talked about in the
keynote speak you want to be close to
the data as possible look at Raw samples
look at things beyond the aggregated
data look at a variety of Statistics
visualize your data uh make sure that
you really understand the mechanisms and
the edge cases and the null values and
what causes them this will make sure
that you can really reason about the
different phenomenas that you're seeing
um do back of the envelope upsizing
basically use simplified assumption ions
uh try to figure out of the various
suggestions what is going to move your
North Star metric and by how
much acknowledge when you don't really
need data and when I was starting out I
assumed that more experienced data
scientists are the one that can come up
with more advanced ways to make
predictions more accurately um and what
I realized is that a lot of the time
what you really gain with experience is
realizing when you can do really simpler
stuff that will be just as good so if
you can do some stuff based on
observational data with some correction
for the bias and it will be just as good
as going down the path of building this
experiment for 6 months that's probably
going to be good enough um this is a
framework that I kind of like to use
about figuring out how much uncertainty
you have around a certain direction and
then also how much complex it's going to
be and the further you are to the top
right you need stronger data evidence if
you're closer to the bottom left you can
kind of you don't really need data
um uh uh yeah I think I'll skip that
other side here's the checklist of
things that we feel help you uh be
successful as a practitioner in this
role um to summarize our
takeaways without uh data you're just a
person with an opinion make sure the
stats are tight without an opinion
you're just a person with data make sure
to have this strong opinion wickly held
mindset uh defining a nor metric is one
of the major leverages that we have on
driving strategy um all metrics are
going to be are going to have limits so
acknowledge them and make sure to focus
on users and not on metrics and lastly
um remember
that it's not Academia so things don't
really have to be scientific you can use
simplifying assumptions but it also
can't be Alchemy so don't just use data
that uh makes you feel like you're
correct try to still uh help the data to
find the limitations in your assumptions
and the product direction that you're
going down um these are some quick
references if you want to dive deeper
measure what matters is like the Bible
of okrs um I highly recommend it the
book of why great book about causal
influence Basics and then there's this
talk by Alex Schulz who is now VP of
analytics at meta about how to use
Northstar metrics to drive
growth okay so that was our talk thank
you so much thank
you